while over 80 percent of the country is
double vaccinated the majority of people
in this room are not
his life choice of not having a vaccine
is probably very apparent to him
unfortunately how old i think his
40s i think
yeah 45
the intensive care unit at the royal
free hospital is nowhere near as packed
as when i last walked through the same
doors exactly one year ago
then there were more than 90 critically
ill covered patients spread across the
hospital now there are just 10. with a
poor looking ct scan you're functioning
very well but they do seem relatively
young
jassy nissi is 48 and he's been in
intensive care for over two months
you see my body is shaking
because very weak
and my hand when i want to eat
shaking all my body's shaking and feel
very cold freezing did you get
vaccinated
no no no i was because
i was lazy to be honest with you every
year say tomorrow tomorrow a big mistake
the risks of not being vaccinated seem
to speak themselves on the intensive
care unit basically people are getting
sicker if they don't have the job
it does seem that way
it does seem to keep you out of the
intensive care unit
which is a benefit for that individual
but it's also a benefit for the other
patients you've seen today it allows
beds to be available for people having
cancer operations in the royal freeze
cancer department they're short staffed
and dealing with a backlog of operations
here i speak to marion who didn't want
to appear on camera but her diagnostic
delays in another hospital due to covid
means she's now facing a more complex
procedure the delay is the appointments
at the hospitals
yeah and then waiting a delay waiting
for scans
you have to wait for the scan and then
you have to wait for the result to your
gp
or to the hospital appointment and these
things i appreciate it all takes time
yeah but there are all these delays
do you feel like that those delays are a
result of you know
the nhs has been under a huge strain
because
yes
this consultant surgeon has just come
from seeing a patient who delayed coming
to hospital after being referred by his
gp because he was worried about catching
covet unfortunately when we eventually
got round to
seeing the patient
his cancer had already spread
so we're now dealing with a young
patient in his mid-50s who perhaps that
we've seen in a year ago could have
offered curative surgery we're now
dealing with palliative care yes in
between
the cardiology department has the same
message don't delay if you have a severe
problem but there are pressures here too
the patient here clearly needs a
post-operative bed but with the hospital
at full capacity there are competing
needs we have a patient in a e is
waiting for a cardiac bed and we have
currently this patient behind us that is
undergoing a cardiac procedure
and they are both allocated to the same
bed on the ward so we are waiting for
the bad managers in the hospital
to let us know the right status upstairs
and so while covert numbers are down
especially in intensive care the
pressure on staff remains intense we've
got a big issue with burnout because
actually
even though we're not at those those
high numbers we've never actually gone
back to sort of normal icu pre-covered
that's never really happened so even
they were sort of back to more
manageable numbers of patients we
actually
we're still very very stretched the
royal free full to the brim short on
staff but in some ways very stretched is
a relief
jason farrell sky news